questions from Dave and Illinois Chase
Bank just came out with a feature on the
app to open up a Roth IRA account right
on the app my question is which
direction would you go with a broker or
this app I'm not sure what the
differences are when opening a Roth with
a bank or with a broker
well apps generally don't have any
advice for you except stuff that would
be set up on an automated basis like
there's investing called Robo investing
now that is all automated and it's just
there's not a person to talk to involved
here I work too hard for my money to
turn it over to an app I work too hard
for my money to turn any amount of
anything over to chase
for God's sakes what a horrible idea and
I worked too hard to allow a bank which
primary job is to get people in debt to
do my investing I don't go the
transmission shop to buy mufflers I
don't go the muffler shop to buy
transmissions I don't go the bank for
investing banks are where you have
savings accounts checking accounts and
they loan you money and get you in debt
that's what they do it's really all they
do they're not in the investing business
well they're in the investing business
but it's certainly not their
specialization it's a sidebar thing I
don't buy my insurance at banks I don't
buy no investments at banks and I don't
buy my shoes at banks but they're apt to
sell you almost anything because they
just love making money no I'll do my
investing with a good investment broker
it's an actual human being that I can
sit down with who will talk to me and
tell me what's going on I know a lot
about investing I know a lot about
mutual funds have been licensed and all
of that stuff used to sell it years ago
I'm studying it for 40 years
I'm very competent and confident and
running my own investments but I don't
I can you know I might we were driving
down the road the other day and out in
the country and my my wife said what's
that and this guy the pickup in front of
us had a trailer behind his pickup and
he had the hydraulic item on the trailer
that you used to pull engine if you're
gonna take an engine out of a car the
jagged Jack's the engine up out of the
car you have to take the engine loose
and take all the parts loose and
everything then you lift the engine out
of the car if you're gonna change the
engine out or whatever I happen to know
what there was because I've done that
but I don't do that now
I opened the hood on my Corvette the
other day and it looks more like a
computer than an engine to me and so the
chances of me doing that are zero even
though I probably could figure it might
figure it out I don't DIY my own cars
anymore and I don't DIY do it yourself
my own investments anymore
I don't even DIY my own taxes I don't
DIY my own state plan I have people that
are known as professionals that know
what the flip they're doing they sit
down show me what we're doing I
understand it and then we do it meaning
they have the heart of a teacher and
that's how you pick investments you can
do it you can read two books that to
make you an expert and three articles on
Motley Fool and then you'll be a fool
you know
and all of a sudden you're about to lose
your butt because you don't know what
you're doing and the first time that
Donald Trump or North Korea boy burps
and the market moves you're gonna freak
out and make the exact wrong financial
decision at the exact wrong time because
you don't have anyone in your corner
coaching you through and telling you to
slow down so this is why I recommend
investment advisors I personally use an
investment advisor and did I mention I
know a lot about this and yet I have
people that but I don't sit look at
mutual funds all day long you know what
this nerd does that works with me on REO
smart mr. Pro he's a nerd he's a one of
my best friends but he is a nerd and his
whole job his whole life is look at
mutual funds all day long just shoot me
no thank you I don't want to do that all
day long but he knows more about mutual
funds and his pinky
than any six of you put together with
your theories and discussing them with
your brother-in-law over Thanksgiving
dinner and two of you had gotten that
worth a $4 put together but you got a
lot of opinions see this is how people
do they just it's dumb they take more
financial advice from their golfing
buddy than they do from a professional
and then wonder why I lost money when
your market went down well of course you
did your golfing buddy is your financial
adviser give me a break and he can't
even play golf I mean come on gee so now
you get a financial advisor you get
somebody in your corner and the way you
do that should click smart Wester at
Dave Ramsey com put in your information
it will drop the list of the smart
Wester pros in your area down you get to
choose which one these are the people we
have vetted that we feel good about our
team spends a lot of time and a lot of
my money digging in and knowing them
about these people to make sure they're
straight up and that they have the heart
of a teacher and that's you sit down
with somebody like that you don't use an
app you use an app to play solitaire you
don't use an app to do your investing